there's nothing quite like a good shock
at the movies and while everyone loves
to see their heroes live happily ever
after
sometimes audiences need a reminder that
life isn't all sunshine and roses here
are a few movies where the villain
actually wins
the star wars universe is no stranger to
a villainous victory or two with warring
space factions trading constant blows
back and forth
across various conflicts rogue one and
revenge of the sith
certainly end on some downloads for
example but the series most iconic dark
side victory came in the middle chapter
of the original
trilogy following the first film which
left off on a death star destroying hai
the empire strikes back came crashing
back down to reality when it opened with
the crushing defeat of the rebel forces
on half
while the movie splinters at that point
with various characters heading off to
do their own thing
the paths of the protagonists ultimately
lead back to lando calrissian's floating
heaven of cloud city
unfortunately when darth vader and his
minion show up to carwysion city
things quickly go south for pretty much
everyone han solo is tortured and used
as a test subject for carbon freezing
leaving him in suspended animation
carissian loses cloud city to the empire
meanwhile luke is lured into a trap and
confronted with one of cinema's greatest
ever twists
needless to say there's no doubt that
empire's final act is a home run for
vader and the empire from start to
finish
the 2008 film valkyrie is inspired by
the failed assassination attempt made
against adolf hitler in the summer
of 1944 by a cabal of german officers
aiming to overthrow the nazi regime
colonel claus von staultenberg joins
major general henning vontresco and a
member of other conspirators
who set up a plan to kill off the
dictator and use the reserve army to
maintain order and establish themselves
as the new government from there they
plan to use their power to negotiate
favorable peace terms with the allies
who at that point are on the clear path
to victory
the film follows the story just as it
actually unfolded with everything
seeming to move towards victory for von
stalfenburg and his co-conspirators
in fact the movie does it so well it
almost makes you forget that you already
know what's about to go down
but alas valkyrie is ruthlessly tethered
to reality
initially the assassination comes
tantalizingly close to success
with the planted explosives going off
successfully and operation valkyrie
being put into action
but before long reports surface that
hitler survived the explosion
and from there the whole plot collapses
the movie ends with hitler still alive
and the film's heroes executed
for treason which is about as bad as
things possibly could have gone over the
years marvel comics have seen plenty of
tragic endings and grisly cliffhangers
but the mcu itself has tended to prefer
the good guys to come out on top but
this trend has recently begun to change
having kicked off in earnest when
captain america civil war putted the
avengers against one another
leaving a host of angry ptsd ridden
superheroes behind in the process
this slide downhill only sped up with
thor ragnarok an otherwise fun movie
that ended with asgard destroyed and a
small handful of survivors setting out
in search of a new home but it was only
drawing avenger to infinity war that
marvel finally opened up a universe
in which the villains really can win the
colossal crossover event finds the hero
struggling to rise up and defend the
universe
against thanos and his cronies only for
the mad titan to finally pull off his
cataclysmic finger snap and wipe out
half the universe in the process
i am inevitable
while much of thanos's mad destruction
was undone in avengers end game infinity
war was nonetheless
so focused on thanos and his story that
his victory during the film's closing
moments
was never anything but inevitable
seven follows detectives william
somerset and david mills as they
investigate a series of murders by a
mysterious criminal who uses the seven
deadly sins as his calling card the
movie gains speed as the duo and cover
the first five sins
but before the last two take place the
murderer known as john doe
turns himself into the authorities while
covered in the blood of an unknown
victim
as the movie wraps up the growing sense
of impending doom becomes practically
unbearable
though directs mills on summer sets to
the desert where he informs them that
the last two victims will be found
of course they're already present as doe
confesses to being envious of mill's
idyllic life with his pregnant wife
tracy before a box arrives on the scene
containing tracy's head inside mills
then gives into temptation and kills doe
who becomes the final victim of wrath
aside from being messed up in so many
ways seven's plot is never in the hands
of the movie's protagonist
with doe in total control right up until
the credits roll
christopher nolan's the dark knights
delivered more than just an outstanding
performance from a greatly missed actor
since heath ledger's joker was also one
of the first superhero villains to have
his way with the hero from beginning to
end
from the moment he enters that dramatic
opening heist sequence says last laugh
during the film's climax the infamous dc
villain easily steals the show
the dark knight revolves almost entirely
around the joker schemes against gotham
and batman
many of which are pulled off without a
hitch as a result this second film in
nolan's epic trilogy leaves rachel dawes
dead
harvey dent warped into two-face and
killed soon after
batman on the run after taking
responsibility for dense crimes
and the bat signal destroyed by
commissioner gordon see madness as you
know
is like gravity
all it takes is a little push and sure
the joker is eventually apprehended and
has his nihilistic philosophy thoroughly
disproven by the people of gotham at the
same time but everything else went off
about as well as he could have hoped
christopher nolan appears to have
something of a gift for letting the
villains win
in this case you've got memento the
narrative follows leonard shelby
a man who suffers from memory lost every
five minutes this
is a recent affliction that has been
occurring ever since two men assaulted
and murdered his wife after shelby
killed one of them the other knocked him
on the head and escaped leaving him with
his new mental handicap
shelby is dead set on hunting down the
other man responsible for his wife's
death but plagued with short-term memory
loss
he is forced to use tattoos and polaroid
cameras in an elaborate system to remind
himself of what he discovers
the movie is filmed in both color and
black and white sequences showing
different
angles of perception and giving a sense
of bizarre confusion that helps the
audiences relate to the film's hero
except shelby isn't the hero as the
movie concludes we find that he has been
cyclistically hunting down and taking
vengeance on innocent people for a year
repressing this information shelby
tampers with his own photographic
evidence allowing his condition to wash
your guilt away within the next few
minutes
and permitting him to continue his
villainous behavior
while peter jackson's film adaptation of
jrr tolkien's or inspiring lord of the
rings trilogy
has many happy moments during its run
time the ending of the first film the
fellowship of the ring
isn't one of them as the film reaches
its crescendo the fellowship has already
gone through the devastating loss of
gandalf but things go from bad to worse
as the forces of mordor close in on them
boromir kicks things off by falling to
the lore of the ring and attempting to
take it from frodo
unsuccessful and repentant boromir and
the rest of the heroes turn their
attention to a sudden attack of aurahai
soldiers
sent by soroman to find the ring the
attack splits the group up with the
villains killing boromir and
successfully carrying off the hobbits
mary and pippin frodo meanwhile leaves
with sam across the river
and the two begin to work their way
towards mordor alone all in all this
ending is about as chaotic as it gets
and doesn't lead to any one of the
protagonists actually getting their way
though triumph lies ahead the truth is
that fellowship is a movie about the
power of camaraderie
that nonetheless tears its characters
away from each other during its final
moments
and that's about as bleak as it gets
though it's outside the cannon of the
mcu and doesn't have quite as
catastrophic and ending as infinity war
x-men first class has another marvel
movie that doesn't reward its heroes
with a happy ending
in this prequel to the original x-men
movies the story line jumps back in time
to the 1960s
to explore the origin stories of its
heroes and villains in particular the
film focuses on the development of the
relationship between professor charles
xavier
and eric lyncher which is the story of a
profound and meaningful friendship
right up until it isn't we have it in us
to be the better man
we already are we're the next stage of
human evolution you said it yourself
while the movie itself brought a fresh
spin to a flagging franchise
its story ended on a dark note with the
rise of an iconic marvel villain magneto
as the film enters its final act
the differences between xaviers and
lynch's views on mutant activism come to
a head with lyncher dramatically parting
way to the critically wounded xavier and
his team
this sets him on a journey towards
becoming the franchise's most notable
villain
and begins a rivalry fated to go down in
history
like valkyrie life is beautiful it's
another story that ends with the nazis
coming out on top
this classic italian film was directed
and co-written by the incredibly
talented roberto benini
who also played the lead role alongside
nicoletti broski
his wife of nearly 30 years the first
half of the film is almost entirely
light and comedic as it follows guido
a jewish bookshop owner in italy who
shamelessly pursues the love of his life
with a little slapstick clowning and a
lot of italian charm but things take a
drastic term when the narrative jumps
forward several years to a nazi occupied
italy where guido his wife and their son
are sent to a concentration camp once in
the camp the bookshop owner uses his
incredibly resilient imagination
to tirelessly shield his son from the
horrors around them convincing the young
boy that they're on a strange kind of
holiday
despite the subject matter the movie
does actually build toward a happy
ending
until in a gut-wrenching turn guido is
gunned down by nazis just as the camp is
liberated
and while guido's son's innocence is
preserved the loss of the film's lovable
protagonist is nonetheless a shocking
note for the film to end on
just like the classic 1949 george orwell
novel on which it's based
the movie 1984 is about as depressing as
it gets from the infamous thought police
to the near endless torture brainwashing
and doublethink this movie pretty much
established all the classic
tropes of futuristic dystopian horror
the film is set in a world where the
single united super state of oceania is
run like a well-oiled autocratic machine
in which every move and thought of its
inhabitants are scrutinized for any
deviation from government-approved
behavior
the story follows winston smith a
supposedly loyal worker at the ministry
of truth
smith deviates from the rules when he
meets julia and begins to secretly
pursue an affair with a daring fellow
thought criminal
of course government forces proved much
more powerful than two people
and the end of the movie shows the
couple as they're caught and put through
a system of rehabilitation
in which they are tortured and forced to
face their greatest fears in order to
break their rebellion
and ensure their future cooperation with
the regime and that's heartbreaking
ending in the cafe
in which julia and winston coldly admit
they betrayed each other leaves no doubt
whatsoever that big brother
has come out on top check out one of our
newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one